what else what else we gonna talk about
jay paul
this guy yes
okay so
interesting actually can i give like a
little hot take i was telling you guys
about this yesterday but i want to drop
this before the jay paul thing uh
floyd mayweather hasn't paid logan paul
for their fight yeah yeah now i told you
guys this yesterday but that [ __ ] was
absolutely crazy yeah so
um yeah i was talking to logan about it
i was like you seriously yeah yeah he
hasn't [ __ ] paid me i guess we're
gonna have to sue them and it sucks
because once you go into the lawsuits
it's like the lawyers make all the money
yeah everybody's losing exactly you
could stretch that [ __ ] out forever you
know and uh he owes him probably between
like five and ten million dollars he has
not paid him it's been six months now
he's supposed to pay him within 90 days
and they have not paid him and then
apparently they cut a side deal
with like saudi arabia and then one
other place for like 10 million dollars
to stream the fight there and never told
logan or their people about it and it's
just like
it sucks to like i'm the biggest floyd
mayweather fan in the world right he is
the greatest fighter of all time i've
said he's the greatest great of all time
but it sucks to see people become
the people that they've always fought
against or hated right you know like
floyd left bob arum because he was like
bob aaron's not giving me the money i
deserve he's [ __ ] me right barbara's
iconic promoter in boxing and it's just
like and then you end up becoming that
yeah that's some [ __ ] man it's like
you know the fight generated money pay
the guy pennies compared to what you're
paying yeah like why do that what what
the [ __ ] is are you embarrassed that you
didn't finish him is this like a power
play this is a little bit of an ego move
but like why are you becoming the guy
that fighters all say and swear they're
not gonna be and they're gonna come into
the promotional business and
revolutionize it and pay the fighters
their fair share et cetera and then
you're just going to be a scumbag to
this guy
the last 30 days have been kind of
embarrassing for floyd i don't know if
you saw the thing where he said like
fendi outfit he dressed like little
dirk's girlfriend in russia that [ __ ]
was crazy
he said also like if i had trained for
logan at all i'd have knocked him out in
the first round it's like all right you
got to say that yeah just do it yeah
just do it and you're all your whole
ethos all work is easy work yeah so you
didn't want to do the easy work yeah
you're the guy who
we respect above all else you work the
[ __ ] hardest yeah so now you're like
i'm not even doing that and that to me
undermines your legacy more than
carrying him for eight rounds to have a
fun fight yeah just you know i just
don't even address it yeah it's just
corny man it makes me wonder it's like
are they going through real financial
problems also if i'm his fighter javante
davis i'm like yo check the books yeah
i'm like yeah please don't let this be
another don king situation where don
king was ripping off these fighters back
in the day
and
i don't know it's just so sad like that
would be the biggest stain on his legacy
if at the end of the day he ended up
[ __ ] over his fighters not only logan
but like [ __ ] over trevante and other
people as part of mayweather promotions
like
you want to talk about something that
could be a stain like not knocking out
logan paul people can forget about we
remember floyd he's 50 and oh and never
lost a fight yada yada yeah we don't
care about these stupid uh uh exhibition
bouts he was doing he went did one
against some japanese kid like we don't
give a [ __ ] about that but what could
[ __ ] up your legacy is if you end up
being a scumbag to fighters the people
that you were swearing to protect right
right the wheel that you were swearing a
break it's like some [ __ ] uh
targaryen daenerys [ __ ] yeah it's like
did you just become
the crazy yeah people that you were
trying to fight back against oh yeah
it's like that new um matrix uh movie
that just came out i don't know if you
guys remember remember nairobi uh jada
yes character in the early matrices she
was
this rebel
and in this one she's this person
pushing back against the rebels and it's
like you live long enough to become the
person that you hate right right i think
there's that batman line like uh what is
it uh die here or live long enough to
become a villain yeah die here live long
enough to become villain
memory right there there you go yeah and
uh and it's like is that what we're
witnessing with with floyd and that
would stain his legacy
that would i think that would [ __ ] him
up his legacy as a fighter you think
though like is he not going to be one of
the greatest man yeah as a man for sure
dude he got a couple things against him
a great reputation as a man
a couple accusations he is the man's man
i think it's only gonna matter to people
like you who are big fans of him yeah i
think you're right because the rest of
the general public they don't give a
[ __ ] now here's another thing i'm
wondering do you think there's a certain
part of
society
that like maybe doesn't like
logan yeah and the paul paul brothers
and they actually
are happy that floyd is [ __ ] him over
in this way is kind of hustling him
maybe but like you it's like such an
injustice that even the biggest hater is
going to be like
because don't most people go yo if i did
something you didn't pay me like i would
be furious about this especially
fighting
risky
high yeah yeah
i mean it just feels so weird it's like
the scummiest thing right like something
just seems off because to not pay him at
all
or give weird it's like gifts
the fact that he didn't pay him at all
and so i'm what i think my theory is
that it didn't sell the way that he
thought
and so he's gonna have to pay him out of
pocket
and and it's different when you coming
out of your pocket than when you're
coming out of profits yeah pocket feels
harsher
yeah when you make crazy money it's nice
to like throw it around
interesting but i think they confirmed
that it did sell well i mean maybe the
business wasn't right like you know they
kind of put this [ __ ] together pretty
quick yeah that's true interesting so
there's something else there like i want
to talk to floyd obviously i wish i had
connect with him like that to actually
get his side but it just feels wrong bro
like yeah well i don't know about the
saudi thing though like if you are able
like it was it floyd's thing like it was
his production his promotion to put it
on yeah so if they find other ways to
monetize it yeah i don't think you're as
entitled to that it's kind of [ __ ] up
i guess but like i think based on their
contract it was a percentage of what the
fight earned ah okay and then just not
telling him about that money earned so
if he was going to get ten percent of
everything that came in and you know
floyd gets the hundred million and he or
100 million comes in it's like floyd
gets 90 he gets a 10. it's like well fam
where's my 1 million from that 10
million deal you did in saudi arabia the
contract would easily say like worldwide
and if it was
carving out saudi arabia that'd be very
clear yeah
yeah i don't know it just feels like
scummy though but
one good thing i could say about floyd
hairline's looking fantasy
his surgery
was amazing it worked because he had
plugs on his face and and his head yeah
and it's not like because tory's [ __ ]
and maybe he was stressed with the whole
megan thing but tory's [ __ ] is gone but
now floyd is just looking youthful yeah
he looked like dr umar he needed that
logan paul money that's what he did
he's like i can't give this up
[Applause]
you